well the henderson silver knights will
soon have a permanent home to play their
games the dollar loan center arena is on
track now for a spring completion sports
director chris matthews giving us the
most exclusive look inside this
multi-million dollar facility chris
well thank you very much denise yeah
this 84 million dollar facility will be
the seventh arena here in southern
nevada now the dollar loan center you
can see over my shoulder here will be
the primary home for the ihl's henderson
silver nights it will also be home to
the indoor football league's vegas
nighthawks and of course a bunch of
other sporting events and concerts
we had a chance to take a deep dive into
this new 6 000 seat arena today now this
facility as knights owner bill foley
says will be better than t-mobile arena
it just won't have eighteen thousand
seats it will be a multi-events venue
ice rink basketball court indoor
football field and of course it'll stage
concerts and we took a lot of the great
ideas from t-mobile it's a fantastic
facility the fortress as we like to call
it uh we're proud to be there
but as we thought about the american
hockey league you know what would be
those things that would that we could
take from the t-mobile concept shrink it
down to an american hockey league size
we're going to have everything from
basketball to hockey to indoor football
concerts
any other type of events we're really
going to make this a multi-faceted venue
it's going to be very very very busy all
year long of course hoops hockey they're
going to take occupancy of this bill
foley and henderson on february 1st the
first sporting event will be the big
west basketball championships reporting
from henderson outside the dollar loan
center i'm chris matthews 8 sports now